not only are we living in this shitbox
mansion in this horrific neighborhood
where everybody hates us because we're
the white family but my nanny or
whatever you want to call him
housekeeper is wearing a wig big black
guy wig high heels and a dress while
mopping he taught me how to drive a
stick he taught me how to fist fight he
taught me how to shave he taught me how
to put the seat up so I learned how to
be a man by this guy in a wig now I
can't get an erection unless I see a
picture of RuPaul
[ __ ] moment look at this show hey thanks
for having me boy these thighs are
magical I got them out for you I love
them
put honey on them and eat them look at
this and the guns and the hairline my
God the hairline look at that thing it's
it's Perfection what can I say uh
speaking of Honey Cocaine bear have you
heard of cocaine back I know I think is
that gay porn no
hottest movie trended on Twitter
yesterday based on a real story in
November 1985 a hunter discovered a dead
175 pound black bear in Chattahoochee
National Forest nearby was a duffel bag
that had originally contained roughly 75
pounds of cocaine the unfortunate animal
had apparently gotten into the blow and
overdosed later dubbed Pablo Esco bear
or simply cocaine bear and now they're
making a movie about it oh I hope Pixar
is all over this
uh by the way that's 85 before fentanyl
you know that bear would have been dead
in two seconds but at least he probably
had a good run around the forest with
that coke yeah I know but yeah that's
the thing dude you know you've got to
scrape the barrel if you're not going to
do more redones of top gun
that has taken cocaine that's what's
happening next that's gold I love it and
nobody gets hurt you can't cancel
anybody it's fun he's all right black
bear weren't being inclusive
sorry what'd you say the bed's not very
happy no no but you get a bear you know
he won't really do Coke in the movie
yeah it'll be fake Coke and it'll also
be a fake bet apparently he's on display
the guy it's been what's it called when
you do it Taxidermy yeah Taxidermy
cocaine bar whoa serious [ __ ] still got
the white stuff on his muzzle and
everything damn that's awesome good for
the bear yeah I think you had a good
time um another thing happy like he went
out like Rick James
I remembered that tweet from that lady a
few it was about 10 years ago do you
remember she there was some lady that
was flying to Africa oh yeah the AIDS
lady
dude that story came back up again what
I just I it resurfaced someone was
reflecting it because it's nearly 10
years since it happened and that was
still that was like cancellation before
cancellation right so for the people
that don't know this lady was flying to
Africa South Africa I think and tweeted
um going to Africa hope I don't get AIDS
just kidding I'm white and she got on
the plane with a life and a career and
got off the plane and it was
all gone yeah poor girl that's not a bad
that's not that bad there's a lot of
AIDS in Africa
uh not really amongst the whites I mean
if you go with the statistics I'm with
her
hey you know it's a funny joke but uh
that should be a mini series like HBO
like black mirror and all that how about
all the true cancels throughout the last
you know get Kramer in there get uh the
AIDS lady get Roseanne remember the
ambient tweet wow that would be
interesting that would be good each one
is a different character each one is a
different story cancellation Through the
Ages exactly see what they had and see
what they lost Roseanne had the biggest
show on Netflix that went away you know
that that's fun stuff it seems like I
mean is there anyone Trump gone now back
there's no one really that's too big to
to topple I don't think is there anyone
that's outside of the cancellation verse
Chappelle seems pretty uh Invincible yes
he's quarantined somehow yeah I don't
know how I think he just doesn't care
and he's a cool black guy and he sells
out everywhere if you have the capital
you can kind of Beat It I lied to JK
Rowling ah there's another one Capital
she's a zillionaire yes I think ability
to win people money is just a protective
mechanism right cute why would you kill
the Golden Goose right right yeah which
is kind of fun because it shows how much
[ __ ] a lot of this is because
they're like yes that's horrible oh wait
you know let's not say it about her
let's not say it about him oh he doesn't
how much does he not put your 10 mil no
yeah we can get rid of him exactly yeah
Alec Baldwin's still working wow [ __ ]
dude that's insane I talked about a life
changing like that
bro brutal poor guy
well he's back on filming the same movie
is he yeah oh man imagine that one year
finally we get back to set Jesus Christ
yeah geez I hope they got a new um prop
guy
you know that gun guy whoever that was
or that lady
duh [ __ ] dude I mean that's that's one
of the wildest one of the wildest and
that's just gone you know that's just
like in the past that feels like it was
the same as the AIDS lady ten years ago
now right it's not yeah there was a big
one in New York uh Central Park right
when BLM was really cooking there was a
lady who yelled at a black guy about a
dog I remember I remember I saw she was
on a podcast she's living in Sweden
somewhere super far away and just had to
start a whole new life she had to quit
her job move out of her apartment her
family got doxed you know they got
yelled because of that one video the one
video the whole thing and she's like she
explained her side of it and you're kind
of like wow we were really hard on that
lead what was her side of it basically
that uh the black guy knew what he was
doing by calling the cops and being and
saying what he was saying and she's like
no if you listen to the video she's like
there's an African-American here like
she's even calling him an
African-American she's not like there's
a black guy you know and then she said
it's not my first running with that guy
and that guy had a lot of other people
who hated him so he was like a menace to
other people but those people were too
scared to chime in because they didn't
want to get killed you know so
I'm not saying she's completely Innocent
but I am saying there's more to the
story there's always more Nuance is the
new n-word I always say because we don't
like we don't like Nuance we go good guy
bad guy that's it yeah like Martin
Luther King hated gays you know yeah
he's super religious Southern Baptist
okay yeah I don't know man I think as
soon as you you've got character limits
on whatever you're going to do on the
internet you're inevitably going to Tamp
down the resolution that you can look at
[ __ ] through right totally like you
haven't got the spec you literally do
not have the physical space but what
that does is it creates a sort of a
feedback loop of people not wanting to
think in anything more descriptive than
240 characters right not only is that
the platform but it then sort of informs
the style of thinking and the depth of
thinking that people have yeah
completely and it's just written there
you can you can take it from there and
put it other places whereas a comedy set
sure you're getting laughs and you're
saying the same exact thing you might
say on Twitter but it's loosey-goosey
and there's people laughing and it's a
context with Twitter's just right there
in the cement dried bro it's everybody
on the planet is probably
80 characters away from completely
ending their life completely I wonder I
want to know what is the fewest number
of characters that it's taken for
somebody to completely destroy
themselves well I mean the n-word is
five letters right that's pretty quick
that's quick yeah maybe f-a-g is quicker
that's three yeah I don't know whether
you would you get full on canceled for
the f word do you think probably just
did that probably not it'd have to be in
a context yeah and you guys with the
cigarettes that might give you a little
more leeway difficult yeah well people
still say that like consistently in the
UK oh really I'm just gonna pop out I'm
from the north so we'd say tab pop out
for a tab instead of instead of that one
yeah yeah yeah nearly nearly stumbled
into it yeah it's um [ __ ] I think is
back dude I had a fascinating
conversation about the word [ __ ] so uh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
imbecile uh and idiot all had previous
medical connotations uh Queen Mary II
her two cousins were uh categorized as
cretins at Birth kept in the special
tower no one attended the funeral
knowing you where they went and it just
happens to be that this one word like
it's kind of arbitrary like why I picked
that word yeah what's the problem with
that one and it seems like the reason
for the problem is that it became
popular yes but you would hear I know
like [ __ ] or [ __ ] or imbecile is the
sort of thing that like a slightly spicy
news anchor would throw around as their
their form of being able to call someone
you know Donald Trump's being such a
[ __ ] with the way that he's but no one
thinks about that even though all of the
words kind of came from the same place
that is fascinating I think you're right
and also the short the shortening of a
word bothers people you know like if you
say he's [ __ ] he's mentally [ __ ]
people go like okay that's a little
nicer but if you go he's a [ __ ] he's
shorting it from all those to two
syllables something about shortening a
word like uh I'm sure there's another
example like a homosexual
totally fine homo bad people don't like
the shortening I think that it's it
makes it feel like more of a pejorative
yes right that's what it is you would
use the shorter version maybe it's also
indicative of the fact that you maybe
throw the word around quite a lot yeah
so I gotta I gotta be efficient if I'm
gonna say it a lot of the time right
right I guess so but it's weird because
the opposite is with names like you got
Gregory but you call him Greg that's a
nickname so it's weird if you're
shorting a name we love you if you
shorten a term we hate you
um yeah I do want to do I wanna I want
someone to do a study where they look at
what is the smallest number of
characters that it's taken someone to
cancel themselves on Twitter yeah that'd
be great and then you could have a chart
you could have like a leaderboard I love
it like this guy's currently running at
15 characters how amazing and then
someone comes in with a 14 and the whole
world loses it Minds that's a fun time
that should be in the Olympics that
would spice it up a little more the
ratings aren't great yeah man so I'm
pretty new in Austin though so it's it's
relatively uh getting used to everything
here getting used to the new terminology
and learning how to communicate with you
guys despite the fact that it's the same
language it's been something that's been
a little bit of a learning curve that
being said Austin's kind of subsumed my
personality now so I play Pickleball
I have a nice ice tub and I've got
everything I've gone full full ass and
do podcasting shorts yeah good for you
and but you gotta remember this is still
Texas like you go to New York it'll be
different or La it's different culture
and conversations and words you can't
say this is still Yeehaw no abortion
speaking of that the uh the Karen lady
that you spoke about I got shouted at on
the pickleball court yesterday by a lady
walking her dog for celebrating too
loudly she said that it was a park and
it was supposed to be a peaceful place
oh yeah they they're carrying things
continuing they can't really complain
about them asking so much anymore so
perhaps they've transmuted that onto
something else I don't know I love the
irony of being a peaceful place but
she's combating with you you know like
what a [ __ ] get out of here also the the
whole Karen thing and the uh kind of
social justice thing are starting to
kind of cross a little bit how do you
mean well the Karen people are like hey
don't celebrate like that and then you
know some social justice people like hey
don't say that word they're very similar
I would also say that a lot of uh social
justice people are very similar police
who they claim to hate you know they're
policing don't say that you can't think
that you can't take a photo with that
guy don't hang out with him it's very
police-like despite the fact that
they're also trying to run that be fun
yeah so that's and then also very trumpy
very dictatory like you see some lady
with blue hair and she's like hey shut
this down this can't happen ball and
you're like whoa easy Sister We're just
trying to have a good time very trumpy I
do wonder why
whether it's someone trying to
compensate for a lack of control in
their own life I don't know it's strange
it's strange why someone would lean into
that that style of authoritarianism I do
get the sense that it's people that feel
like they don't really have much control
or don't want to lean into control yeah
so they try to control everybody else
instead of taking control of themselves
yeah and now they have this this uh
stance of like well I'm doing good you
know like she's she's saying hey quiet
down this is a peaceful place in her
mind she's the the winner she's the the
the morally Superior so they use that as
this weird way to to win he wasn't just
controlling where's home for you oh
sorry I'm boring you're here no no no uh
um New Orleans I'm born born and raised
New Orleans Louisiana and then I'm I've
been in New York for like 15 years is
that uh I can't pick up an American
accent yet so if you got is that New
Orleans the accent I've been told I
don't sound like I got a weird voice but
I don't think I sound Southern
Southern's like how y'all doing you know
a lot of Southern and Southerners in
Texas obviously
how is everybody you know but uh I don't
know I think I never liked it growing up
so I maybe subconsciously
skewed away why what was childhood like
it's fine it was weird but uh I just
hate the southern accent it wouldn't
work for me but I grew up in a weird I
had a weird upbringing I don't know if
you really want to dive into it there
all right so when I was about eight or
seven or eight my parents got a wild
hair up their ass and bought an old
mansion in a poor black neighborhood and
I'm talking Holes in the Floor you know
no windows creaky uh termites uh stray
cats and the neighborhood was horrific
it was like a third world neighborhood
and we fixed it up and they made the
back half of it a bed and breakfast
because it was so big this house was so
big that we couldn't live in all of it
and they needed income for because they
were fixing the place up
so we would like you know have traveling
businessmen and bands come through and
uh random people coming to New Orleans
and then we got a housekeeper who is a
transvestite
so not only are we living in this [ __ ]
box mansion in this horrific
neighborhood where everybody hates us
because we're the white family
but we have people coming in and out who
are Rando people staying at the B and B
and then my nanny or whatever you want
to call them housekeeper is wearing a
wig big black guy wig high heels and a
dress while mopping
wow yeah don't worry I've already
pitched the show to eight networks and
they all said no but it was it sounds
weird but that was normal to me
um were you working were you somehow
either the maid were you cleaning in
some capacity I was so young I was going
to school and then I would come home and
skateboard and you know Play and play I
would play basketball in the Parlor
because it was so big I'd put a hoop up
on the wall
and then he was uh he was he taught me
my dad was a workaholic so Enos was the
guy's name he taught me how to drive a
stick he taught me how to fist fight he
taught me how to shave he taught me how
to put the seat up all the so I learned
how to be a man by this guy in a wig and
uh now I can't get an erection unless I
see a picture of RuPaul
no I'm joking but um yeah true story
but that would have been I'm gonna guess
not somebody identifying as a different
gender that would have been like
whatever
80s to 90s cross-dressing cross-dresser
that's what it was and he would do
burlesque at night with like a big Boa
you know and dancing and kicking and all
that Cabaret is interesting man Cabaret
is a group of people like some of the
most sexually active men in the world
like I've been around a bunch of
different Cabaret acts oh some of the
guys that go up there and do that have
got all of the outgoingness that you
would expect with sort of a theatrical
performer yeah they've got that whole
thespian side but then they've still got
the super drive a lot of them are gay
and they've got the superb Drive of
somebody that wants to have sex with
with a lot of other people as well yeah
I mean well who's more free than those
people I mean we're sitting here doing
push-ups and uh trying to get a dick
pump going and drinking you know eating
Bluetooth those guys are just
comfortable I'm jealous of their comfort
yeah it's um thinking about
gay relationships and the fact that
there's no gatekeeper it's like just two
protagonists you know like there's no
true it's just two people that on
average want to say yes more than you
would do in a normal heterosexual
relationship yeah man that's the dream
I mean if I was a lady I would be so I
would be embarrassed by how hard it is
to [ __ ] me
you know what I mean it's like silly
women get horny obviously women are
super horned up and sexy and hot and
they look great in bed but it's so you
gotta like whine and dine and
conversation where guys are like you
want to go put your dick through this
hole in the wall and I'll blow it you
know like it's just so much it's like
you said it's like less gatekeeping but
I get it that women have the men are
scary we're much more aggressive and all
that so they have to watch out for that
which I get but
come on ladies we have the clock's
ticking you know we could have skipped
this whole movie and just eating each
other out
Brian Long's got this bet in his new act
where he says uh I had a trump supporter
a gay Trump supporter in the front row
and it's strange you know because Trump
supporter he's also gay so you don't
always see that he's the kind of guy
that would like to build a wall but then
put a glory hole in
that's a great joke [ __ ] brilliant
that's a great joke I love it yeah
that's what's great about comedy this
weird thing happened and his weird brain
got cooking and he made this cake of a
joke is that a comedy scene in New
Orleans there is it's small and it's
it's not really a comedy club there you
need a club that'll really like be the
base you know but uh the problem with
comedy New Orleans is it's it's already
such a Party City and people go there to
get [ __ ] up have a bachelor party go
to Mardi Gras Jazz Fest so comedy it's
like we don't want to sit and listen to
a guy talk about anxiety you know like
we want to go get [ __ ] housed and comedy
is a lot of it is built through pain and
all that and I think people are there to
live it up and so they don't want to
hear a non-famous person talk about
comedy or talk about Uber yeah well I
suppose if you're walking down Bourbon
Street and you've got loud music loud
music loud music sad story loud music
loud it's like the sad story probably
not that competitive yeah exactly it's
it's tits you know you're gonna go past
the tit place to watch a guy uh go oh my
answer [ __ ] you know so it's hard to
it's hard for comedy to thrive there
there was one country music bar that I
noticed on Bourbon Street in New Orleans
and I did notice that there was a
significant difference in the sort of
clientele between that and Jazz bars on
either side yeah yeah interesting you
got to have your every place has their
Embassy you know black people like we
feel safe here and then rednecks like
this is our spot and then you know the
rest of us
Bourbon Street and Beignets at that
place it's open 24 hours that's it
unbelievable very good yeah that that
powdered sugar all over you you look
like the cocaine bear that's the coke
that's maybe that's where he went maybe
maybe it was a plan for someone to put
the 75 pounds of cocaine next to him and
it was actually a bunch of Beignets and
he just left it dude I went to uh New
Orleans a few years ago and it was just
before 2019 just before some sort of
storm came through and there was a dude
a homeless guy you know the steps just
up and down from Cafe Du Monde and you
can kind of like people must jump in
pretty regularly I'm gonna guess into
the river yeah and uh this dude was
jumping
hell like this guy's kind of intense
he's sort of a homeless guy and he's
talking slash verbally fighting with
these kids that were kind of taking the
piss out of him anyway there was a new
story that went viral two weeks later
during a hurricane of
um crazy New Orleans man jumps into
River in the middle of hurricane and it
was the same dude wow couldn't believe
it there you go I was like this guy but
that's also what's great about the
internet is like 20 years ago that guy
would just be a nut job yeah now he's a
star now he's a star no he's got his own
only fans
exactly oh speaking of that you remember
the cash me outside girl of course and
she's now one of the number one only
fans girls in the world apparently crazy
dude that's why the female privilege but
all right the lady that was doing dog
walking Mr pivot
ah
all of this traffic good point could
have monetized it good point yeah only
fans is a beautiful thing for that
reason you know because these ladies can
really really have an Empire maximize on
one opportunity if I was the AIDS lady I
would do it only fans right okay race
play as well yeah like I do African
[ __ ] African guy with AIDS you know
fake it but that would be fun have you
seen do you know Adam 22 he does the no
jumper podcast yeah big dong yeah yeah
he if you've seen his new thing that he
does so I'm pretty sure I might be
getting this wrong pretty sure he's got
a podcast that's only on only fun so
he's got no jumper which is his one that
exists on the normal internet then he
has another one and only fans where him
and his wife a partner sit down and have
a conversation with another girl and
then [ __ ] her whoa that's that's the
thing that's it right so it kind of
always finishes the same it's kind of
like I know like a really old version of
Magnum PI or something or Scooby-Doo
yeah you knew it was that person all
along I know how it's going to end oh
that's fun uh but that's the thing so
obviously this is what's intended to be
done today as well
all right well I haven't shaved back
there but that's a great idea boy we
live in a fair I mean look this these
times we live in have horrific thing
things too you get yelled at on Twitter
you get docs you get this and that but
there's also some beautiful stuff going
on Ingenuity yes with the good it's like
fire you know it could burn your house
but it could also warm your house
why New York from New Orleans just for
comedy comedy yeah it's you got a
there's such a low ceiling in New
Orleans for comedy so I had to move to
New York and that's still Center of
America do you think for comedy yes I
think so and it's just I've always
wanted to live there it's the cool it's
the coolest place in in the world I
think and uh
uh New York's kind of like a video game
where you have to just keep going or
you'll die and I need that in life what
do you mean well like I moved to New
York I got mugged three times in a year
my landlord died of AIDS shout out to
the lady and then uh I I got bed bugs so
it's like this city that's it's almost
like the ocean it just keeps trying to
push you out and you got to learn how to
live on on an island how's that how does
that help with anything that's terrible
it keeps me fresh I'm such a lazy come
guzzling douche I will sit down with my
feet up and do a barrel of blow and
mushrooms and watch Netflix and order in
so I need the treadmill to be on or or
else I'll just slip away uh okay so you
need the world to inject some difficulty
into the life or else you're just gonna
continue to be comfortable yeah yeah
that's why I got married
totally uncomfortable but you know you
keep trying [ __ ] you know they they
always say discomfort is key you get too
comfortable you just start to
deteriorate I think you're supposed to
like kind of choose the discomfort
though it's not supposed to be bed bugs
and then yeah dying of it I'm so lazy
that I won't choose it so I need the
city to do it for me I see I see also
it's kind of like an abusive
relationship you know you meet these
guys and they keep dating these psycho
gals or you keep meeting these women who
keep dating these abusive men you're
like what are you doing it's a little
like that with New York I just can't get
away from it you keep coming back to it
I'm Rihanna with Chris Brown I keep
going back
talk to me for someone that isn't uh how
do you say inducted into the world of
performing on stage in front of a ton of
people
what have you learned from bombing on
stage in front of people because I've
heard you say that you're an introvert
yeah and as a compatriot introvert as
well the idea of
not only being on stage which I think I
would I've done before and I get past
but it really failing in a pretty sort
of Majestic Way yeah um what does that
do to you as a person in terms of
learning about whatever yourself or the
world or insecurities well it's a great
question because but that's what's
beautiful about comedy is it's it's real
you know it's it's much like sports
where if you don't throw the ball right
it won't go in the basket it's the same
with comedy if it's not funny they won't
laugh and if it is funny they'll laugh
and there's something great about that
reality that's what I love but also I'm
such a nut job and I have weird thoughts
and maybe my childhood I was outcasts a
lot and a weirdo and all this that I
think stand up you get to say your
thoughts and if you package them the
right way it'll make a room full of
people happy
and I think that's what keeps me going
and I get to go how how weird can I get
how how [ __ ] up can I get and have
them stay with me and then that's a
thrilling thing and the bombing to
answer your question on that I you know
we're all insecure in our own way and
when you bomb it validates every sick
twisted dark thought you ever had you're
boring no one likes you you don't
deserve love you shouldn't be up here
they're right everything they're
thinking is right and you just crumble
and so getting good at stand up is being
able to beat that
and then you you win but when you're
talking about trying to inject
discomfort into your life
that seems like about as much discomfort
as I could think of like shy of being
set on fire yeah it's pretty bad it's
pretty bad a bunch of strangers hate you
but you can beat it and you
see they motivates you to get good at it
um
[Music]
I Wonder has it have you found that it's
changed your personality do you take
anything from outside of Comedy you know
as someone again introverted you go
through these nightly for 15 years 20
years or whatever it is you go through
all of these challenges and it's always
this Specter in the background there's a
dating show in the UK called take me out
and it's where a guy comes down this
lift and all of the girls press the
lights and it's sort of the the fear of
every man that they would get a blackout
and that no girl would want them and
it's sort of that oh wow permanently on
repeat every single sometimes multiple
times per night if you're doing spots
yes uh that has to impact I know the way
you see the world the way that you act
outside of Comedy or does how much of a
crossover is there between your normal
life and your stage life they're pretty
similar I think most Comics are we're
just hardwired so young that we can't
get out of this that's probably why
we're we have a uh every comic you know
you got the fat guy you got the black
guy you got the loud guy you got the
quiet guy you got the dark guy you got
the clean comic that's all imprinted and
it's pretty young I think so
um it doesn't really change your
personality the only way it has changed
is it gives you some meaning you know
like I was always a Wandering through
life guy should I be a waiter maybe I'll
work at a hotel should I be a UPS guy
hey a mailman that seems pretty good so
now with stand up I'm like I have
something to work towards and then you
you do a special and then you go I need
a new special so then you know it keeps
you rolling that ball up a hill and
otherwise I would be rudderless
I see these guys on heroin under the
bridge I'm like I get it that would have
been me yes if not for comedy that would
have been me totally totally I mean if
anything I'd be like working in a
warehouse or something you know like
just with a forklift but I get the
heroin guy there's a lot of hours in the
day there's a lot of bad thoughts
uh you know we're opioids are through
the roof it's like the number one killer
in America we're obsessed with every
other thing except for that I don't know
why no one cares about the opioids but
it's just because hey I'm home I'm sick
of everything let me pop this pill I was
thinking about uh some of the prices
that comedians have to pay I'm
fascinated by the the sort of unseen
price that people pay for the lifestyle
that other people admire so you know a
working comedian who has got specials
and uh platform and people care about
what it is that you do and so on and
then this upcoming Community or maybe
even someone that doesn't understand the
comedy world at all
um I've seen enough of my close friends
that are working comedians now and
understood a good bit about the
lifestyle to know that it's it's not
really
I I you have to be very very disciplined
I think to live the life of a comedian
in a way that doesn't have a ton of
potential externalities that are pretty
negative it seems like everybody in the
green room is constantly drinking you're
doing late nights you're on the road
yeah good bit of loneliness yeah um I
mean you're friends with Constantine and
Francis from the UK oh yeah and
trigonometry and uh I heard about
because the UK's
sufficiently small that you can drive
everywhere to do your shows right so
they basically described this sort of
nocturnal lifestyle permanently in cars
driving to and from when they're on the
doing the the circuit and maybe just a
10 to 30 minute little spot or whatever
they're not actually doing full shows
they're just bouncing around the country
yeah same yeah that's what I do and
isn't that the best to me that's the
best job in the world you get to just go
places pop in do the thing you're the
best at and then leave does not get
lonely I love a loner I like being alone
I'll like I have a great lady at home
she's a love of my life yada yada but
like when I'm on the road I'm like ah
I'm sleeping till noon I'm jerking off I
can eat ice cream and I need that I like
recharge and I come back and I'm
whistling walking in the door hey honey
good to be home and she's the opposite
she's like I was here all weekend alone
I wanted to kill myself and I was like
oh I love being alone I love sitting in
a diner I got a podcast going I'm eating
eggs looking out the window that's the
dream good so given the fact that it
seems like um you're striving to do
excellent things you want to be better
at your craft and you're gonna do a
better hour or about a 10 minutes or
better even just individual joke do you
find that the lifestyle of maybe getting
up a little bit later and and The
Temptations to party and being around
comedians who uh aren't exactly well
known for their discipline sure does
that is is that attention of two
different things there yes totally talk
to me about that well I I'm I first of
all I used to be a janitor I was a
waiter I was a busboy construction
workers so to me being able to do comedy
if making it or not making it it's a
gift it's a privilege I'm a lucky guy
that I get to do this and I get to do it
at this level I'm doing these theaters
now it's it's mind-boggling so I am very
just I feel very grateful to be able to
do comedy
um [ __ ] I lost the question is it a
difficulty sense versus so the obviously
I don't want to go to the gym but I'll
go for comedy you know so I can keep
doing comedy because it'll facilitate
your performance it'll facilitate your
performance it'll it'll make you
healthier it'll make you stronger you
can do you can work longer you know so
yeah sure I want to get hammered but if
I get hammered it'll hurt my show
tomorrow I'll be hungover so I'll drink
a little less so it's all this is what
I'm saying about it gives you a goal it
gives you something to work towards and
I need that so I I've been you know I
don't eat bread I drink less I don't do
blow uh anymore or anything so like I
can really I've really tamped down I
used to be an animal so and I'm you know
39 too but this is in service of your
craft totally totally like Seinfeld once
said he did the show Seinfeld and he
named it Seinfeld just so it would help
him sell tickets on the road it wasn't
like oh it's my ego I need my name on it
he's like oh if I put my name on it
they'll know my name so when I go to
that theater they'll buy tickets and
that's how I feel I'm like I'm at the
gym I'm not like trying to get I'm not
trying to win Mr Universe I just want to
be healthy so I can keep doing comedy
I've been thinking for a long time about
um people treating their chosen Pursuit
like an athlete does so if you think
about how hard athletes work totally
that sleep their nutrition the people
that they spend their time with their
game tape that they watch their mindset
work maybe they're doing breath work or
they're meditating yes they're
considering the hydration they've got a
routine they've got a warm-up procedure
that they go through in advance of doing
the thing that they care about and so
few people
it seems treat the thing that ostensibly
is their life's calling with that same
degree of preparedness 100 I completely
agree and that bothers me yeah I mean I
don't want to be a dick but I see these
comics and they never write they do the
same jokes every time they never try
anything new they they're drunk every
time they go on and I'm like what do you
expect to get out of there you're gonna
get what you put in so like then they go
oh it must be nice to have what you have
I'm like yeah [ __ ] I wrote for three
hours today I worked this out I've been
slaving over this one joke for two years
you know I'm working on it where were
you I did three cities this weekend what
did you do so I hate when people get all
uh look must be nice because I'm like no
no this is it's kind of like when a fat
guy goes hey must be nice to have big
guns and you're like yeah well I do the
curls you know you're eating pasta so
that that bugs me but uh
yeah so I I think yeah you gotta like
you hear these Kobe stories about how
he's the last guy in there and the first
guy in there and Dave Chappelle once
said if you're gonna do stand-up take an
acting class and everybody's like acting
class because it'll help your
impressions your voices your act outs on
stage you know always try to be a little
better and what the things you're not
good at go towards that and try to make
those better and then once you fix that
go to the next thing so I'm all in on
the uh to work hard at the thing think
like an athlete is just a really really
good philosophy I think and here's the
reason why I think most people don't
apart from the fact it's easy not to do
it but
the line between your preparation what
you do in advance and all of that and
your performance is kind of Wiggly three
messy like if you are a power lifter
right that is 300 kilos it's always
going to be 300 kilos it's 300 kilos for
that guy it's 300 kilos on Tuesday it's
300 kilos in [ __ ] Zambia yeah 300
kilos right that's nice so you have very
objective metric of failure or success
it's like if you used to pick up that in
training and then you didn't on game day
what did you do was it your sleep was it
your hydration was it your mindset was
it whatever it was nutrition anything
but when it comes to podcasting or
comedy or pretty much anything except
for sport and maybe like like classical
music players right I really really
thought about this to try and find like
who who else is treating their Pursuit
with that level of
um Precision yeah yeah
um and
very few people because of that
messiness and if you do underperform
you're a speech motivational speaker or
whatever and you get up on stage
tomorrow and you just you sort of thumb
the new words a little bit you forget
your lines and it doesn't really go down
so well and you go well was it because I
stayed up on my phone until four in the
morning right right oh baby but maybe
not and the criteria you can always get
out of jail free cards yeah because it's
subjective yes subjective things always
will make you less uh tenacious I think
because Colin Quinn once said a lot of
comics don't like to write because
writing proves you're not a genius
because you have to work on it and it's
not perfect you crumple the paper you
throw it out but if you go I'll just
I'll figure it out on stage it just it
makes it it makes you get out of jail
free it's like well it didn't work
tonight but I'm tweaking I'm working on
it's like no no no you got to work on it
you're just trying to take a shortcut or
not do anything so I completely agree
and that's why it's even more important
for a comic to be disciplined because
you gotta do it for yourself
because if you can't lift the weight
people go all right so you're that's
exactly how strong you are you can lift
that much with comedy it's like okay I
bombed the night but I did well last
night and I'm getting better and you
know I'm going through a lot right now
you're like all right shut up you're out
yes no one cares about the the last
performance yeah you know the one before
this bad one it's how well did you do
this evening exactly that's why we love
sports you know we love okay the he got
200 points he got 199. he won yes you
know that's why we love UFC he's laying
on the ground he's still standing it's
easy you know and I think those things
are getting more popular because we're
getting in more of a uh emotional based
world I think we're living in I like the
idea of
um the complexity of the world becoming
more simple when you put rules to it yes
so within martial arts within a UFC
fight or even within that which is
essentially like a [ __ ] street fight
that's televised and made legal there
are still rules you know there's an
amount of time that they're there for
there's a weight category can't need
people when their heads on on the ground
you know there are certain things you
can't bite them or kick them in the deck
like there's certain stuff that you
can't and can't do and there are also
relatively even that there's a little
bit of you judge's scorecard type thing
but for the most part it's like if the
guy's on the ground and the other guys
stood up and everything was legal he won
yeah whereas for almost all of the rest
of Life everything's super messy yeah
like how well did I do my morning
routine how good was my interaction with
my kids this morning how
fantastic was my performance with my
partner when we went out for dinner and
how present was I would like it's just
[ __ ] mess it is chaos that's why you
need to have some rigidity in your life
just for your own
self-discipline your own uh you know
self-worth even I ran five miles a day
according my GPS look at that or my step
count whatever that's five miles it's a
hard uh hard number right you know you
need that you know it's it's gets too
wishy-washy with other stuff I'm sure
that guy liked me uh yeah whatever like
well maybe I hated you but people give
themselves too much leeway I think on a
lot of things without that forcing
function or whatever you want to call it
like the the
Focus that you have that everything is
being moved toward that's in service of
right without that um that's why I think
you get list listeners if you don't have
a thing that you're moving toward why do
the hard stuff exactly and that's that's
kind of like a brutal realization
because I think a lot of people have the
capacity to do something or to to put
themselves through really difficult
things like a man with a strong enough y
can bear any how type scenario if you
have that why if you have a why if you
have no y I can guarantee that the how
is probably not going to be done there
are very few people that can do a
Goggins I've heard a rumor that he for
most of this summer was uh volunteering
to fight fires in California being
dropped out of a helicopter holy it's
like a Bushman firefighter just
psychopath yeah right like that's that's
him why because
that's rare right most people need it to
be in service of a thing not just in
service of being a hard [ __ ]
yeah yeah completely completely well I
don't you think there's a reason these
type of guys are popping up there was no
Goggins in the 80s really I mean you had
like Mr Universe or Jack LaLanne or guys
like that but you didn't have these
Andrew huberman's these uh got these Sam
Harris's who are just almost
autistically these are facts this is
reality we need to live in this world
and people are clinging to these type of
people because there's like we need it
it's like you say we're getting so uh
loosey-goosey with everything that
that's why these guys are popular I
think oh because they're creating order
yes from the chaos completely and we we
we go oh okay I'm not crazy I needed
that you know you're just reading
Twitter it's like going you're going
schizophrenic reading that [ __ ] there's
so many opinions coming at once the news
is all horrific mass shooting kids in
cages Jewish space laser what the [ __ ]
going on and then you see Sam Harris
goes well this is because that and
that's why people do this and huberman's
like well neurons in the brain fire and
you're like ah there's an answer there's
reasoning here yes and we love it and
then Goggins is like get your fat ass up
get off the beanbag chair go do a sit up
you come guzzler and we go yeah I need
somebody to yell at me I got a hard on
[Laughter]
we need it
I've heard you say that uh your biggest
fear is an unlived life and did I say
that you did say that although you may
disagree with yourself I do I do that a
lot
um even if you didn't say that or even
if you don't no longer believe it how
how do you try and construct a life to
ensure because I've heard you talk about
Adventures like Adventures I could drive
for you and you want to do sure like a
variety of things
um life is for a living but how do you
how do you keep on doing that how do you
not be you know you can sit back you've
got the the YouTube channel and the
specials and people know you and you've
you know got huge platforms on the
biggest podcasts in the world
how do you not just sit back is it you
know well that's all over I gotta do
that what's the next thing yeah I was on
playing today with two Comics who are
also coming here and they're getting
dropped off of the hotel they're like
where are you going I'm like I'm going
to do a podcast like what why would you
let's go get a drink or let's get dinner
I'm like I like this guy I want to do
his podcast and they're like oh that's
so crazy I'm like yeah but you guys are
gonna sit and eat a taco and talk about
uh the the Bears I'm gonna go talk about
cocaine bear with a guy I've never met
you know so I don't know let's try new
things and that's the beauty of Comedy
is I can I've gone to you know Amsterdam
and Mexico and uh Hawaii and all these
places China I did comedy in China I
would never have gone there without
comedy so yeah let's live baby and and
there's so many people in the cubicle
and uh the plus-size wife and the kids
they hate and the tiny house and they're
[ __ ] Subaru I don't know I want to
mix it up I think far more people didn't
realize it would be able to achieve
something great if they just had
something to work toward I agree that's
why I'm again thankful for comedy
speaking of China have you seen these
videos that are coming out of people uh
protesting against the lockdowns I have
dude this stuff's proper harrowing it's
genuinely yeah there's a really for them
well I suppose so but the fact that it's
got to this stage people have been
quarantined in inside of their own flats
for 100 days and they tied a metal wire
around the door handles from the outside
what so that people people have
literally been locked inside they've got
these drones that fly over the streets
and disperse
some chemicals in a desperate attempt to
try and kill the virus no idea if it
works no idea what the chemicals are
little kids are breathing this in
they've got these totally arbitrary
quarantine areas outside in parks that
are just for uh Bank barriers and it's
just a square with nothing in it and a
sign on the outside it's just the most
insane arbitrary rules wow Runner Mark
it's crazy that is wild that's movie
[ __ ] that's terrifying yes and good for
them for protesting because China is
very obedient you know generalizing but
uh good for them they're Breaking Free
and it's like we said before with the uh
the policing of words like is this
really for good or Justice or is this
something more behind this and I feel
the same way about this is this really
for good the chemicals and the hair the
the [ __ ] on the handles and the doorknob
like
you've gone too far you've gone so far
good you're bad again yeah you know so
think about the price that those people
need to pay to do that protest you know
for all that yeah there was protests
that happened in the US and in and in
the UK and in Australia and people were
unhappy about stuff like you weren't
being tracked by they have this uh gate
tracking uh
AI analysis from CCTV even without
seeing your face with about a 95
accuracy they can work out who you are
just from The Way You Walk oh kind of
like a a biophysical fingerprint of some
kind right and uh that's the price that
they're paying wow for pushing back you
know they're going to have social
credits for they've got this digital
Health what's it called digital
digital Health System digital Health
some [ __ ] and uh the yeah that's it
they're chanting Give Me Freedom or give
me death whoa good for the [ __ ]
serious man serious that is serious [ __ ]
but they can't live like that but I I do
feel bad for them because I think we
talk about how harsh we are with police
I'm sure those police are just coming
down with the hammer yeah game over yeah
yeah that is terrifying but you know we
can't live like this we're losing our
literally losing our lives and they're
like but you could die I'm like well let
me let me take the risk my body my
choice yeah and I do think look I was a
pan you know we had a pandemic and all
that and maybe we're still in one but
and you wear the mask and you play ball
and all that but like there's [ __ ]
limits here folks let's not let's not
overdo it have you heard of frogging
okay so I I got told about this the
other day it's pretty [ __ ] harrowing
story so um one of my friends was uh in
a relationship with some like famous pop
star chick and he was staying at her
house and uh he was sunbathing there and
this guy came through the Hedge he's
like it was [ __ ] strange it's a gated
community like super expensive house and
stuff this guy came through but he was
in khakis or whatever and he looked like
a normal person and uh he was like a can
I help you and this dude looked super
shocked he said oh is this not Scott's
house I'm looking for Scott and he said
no there's no Scott here and he says oh
I I came from next door something must
be I'm sorry I must have got confused or
whatever and my friend just had a bad
feeling about he's like there's
something [ __ ] something up here
something really really up anyway they
uh roll forward another couple of weeks
and he's still got this feeling in the
back of his mind apparently he's waking
up in the middle of the night like he
felt like there was somebody in the room
he's like I'm being crazy I'll go back
to sleep anyway and um air conditioning
goes out so they need to get a peskai
and uh air conditioning guy up so
go upstairs into the the attic and the
he says he'll never forget the body
language the air conditioning guy guy
opens the attic door up goes up and
apparently he just saw him go like
like his whole body language just oh my
God this dude looks so they go for
chills they go up into the at this dude
this story really [ __ ] disturb me go
up into the attic and they look and he
the guy comes back down with his face
just white and he goes uh are you sure
that you've never been up there are you
is this a joke is this some sort of a
joke and he's like no and he's like I
think that you probably need to call the
police it was like okay went upstairs
what had happened was
some like fans or whatever of this
particular person had been living in the
Attic of the house writing manifestos
about how they were going to kill this
person oh
creeping downstairs in the middle of the
night eating the food and then going
back up
dude
oh my God
I believe your friend was banging
Madonna
um holy [ __ ] is that right yeah well we
got robbed a lot when I was a kid and I
I would wake up with people downstairs
and you just know you're getting robbed
and it's a [ __ ] up feeling
so I can I walked in on a few robberies
you know I'm like nine what are you
gonna do yeah it's this big guy with a
TV and I'm like how can I help you and
he's like oh I'm looking for your dad
and I was like oh let me go get him and
then he would just run out their
backyard with a TV what about New York
New York's got some new I've been robbed
in New York got robbed a guy went
through my window in my apartment up the
fire escape opened my window uh walked
on my bed opened a drawer had all this
cash on your bed yeah cause my bed was
in front of the window so he opened it
and walked on the bed so I saw his
Footprints and dirt on the bed and then
didn't wake you up no I wasn't home oh
okay okay yeah crazy story my girl was
living with me at the time she came home
and she opened the door and it hit the
coffee table he had put the coffee table
in front of the door and she's like hey
why'd you put the coffee table in front
of the door and I'm like get the [ __ ]
out of there I knew exactly what was
going on and then she's like okay she
called the police please come the
window's wide open and I'm such an idiot
or a [ __ ] or an imbecile or a [ __ ] that
I had one drawer with like six grand in
it uh a bunch of shrooms uh fireworks
brass knuckles all this dumb all of my
most prized possessions I had it all in
there 18 year old boy [ __ ] you know
baseball cards and a Playboy yeah and he
just scooped all the cash and left
but then they caught the guy they took
one fingerprint and they caught him like
six months later just an old crackhead
guy what so let's say that I'm going to
New York next week actually what are the
biggest do's and don'ts for me while I'm
in New York what should I is there like
a particular uh energy level that I need
to be on or there's some some of the
biggest mistakes that I should and
shouldn't make yeah I will say the it's
all ticked up the craziness is ticked up
since the pandemic because the hobos ran
the city we all went indoors so they
just were running rampant and now the
city's back and they're still there so
there's a real Clash of of normies and
hobo and uh the violence is way up so I
would say have you been before yeah oh
okay okay I would just say don't do the
Subway after midnight why just because
they it gets cold and they go down there
and that's where the real action happens
that's like slashings and uh shootings
and whatnot especially on the track but
I've heard that you've told stories
before about how you needed to do that
because you were was it Brooklyn you
lived in yeah yeah and presumably that's
the only way I mean you're not walking
to [ __ ] Brooklyn no and I had no
money for to get a cab out there because
yeah you know so what do you do if you
have to go just I hope for the best yeah
V for Vendetta I got mugged uh once on
the subway
and that was my fault actually I was at
your fault well I was [ __ ] I drank
too much back then I was blacked out I
fell asleep on the train I woke up to a
guy on his knees doing the exacto knife
around the pockets and I was like I
stood up and I hit my head on the pole
and I fell back down and kind of like
knocked myself out and he was super nice
about it he was like he was so
nonchalant like don't worry the train
will turn it back around I'd gone all
the way to the end which is like hang on
the guy that looked you
made you feel comforted that you missed
your stop he was Charming he was like
don't worry the train will turn around
you'll be all right and then he won't
without your wallet yeah with all my
[ __ ] he had my keys and everything
he's just like all right don't worry
you'll be all right and I was like thank
you
one of my friends who were at a uh a
wedding in Barcelona Barcelona is the
robbery capital of Europe ah and um
the kids there that are playing in the
street they'll be playing football
between them and they've got a whole
system there where they'll kick the ball
towards you and you know that uh sort of
crife turn thing where they jump on the
ball and spin have you ever seen players
do that to turn around players they'll
do that and they'll be able to do that
up against you and take your wallet at
the same time it's like some [ __ ]
Oliver twists yes yes right it's
elaborate and uh yeah one of the guys
doesn't usually drink and we were at
this wedding and he uh big beard sort of
CrossFit guy but big sort of beard and
Slick over here and he decided he just
wanted to have a little nap in Barcelona
train station he woke up to find that
his wallet his phone and his shoes had
been taken from him so you now have this
big beardy guy at seven in the morning
walking around Barcelona City Center but
the problem is he was staying in an
Airbnb he had no um idea what the
specific address of that was obviously
there's no Hotel name or anything right
you go to it's 1945 whatever whatever
yeah and um so he's going up to people
saying can I please borrow your phone
but remember we're in the robbery
capital of Europe so you have this
beardy non-native shoeless with shoes no
shoes walked holes in his Ralph Lauren's
socks like in a wedding suit oh my God
just like the quintessential homeless
guy you're not going to give your phone
to yeah trying to fight against the
exact dynamic that's just robbed him of
all of his possessions oh man that's
wild howdy what happened he eventually
went to a CrossFit gym asked one of the
guys who's like I promise I'm the person
that I say I am uh this is can you go on
Instagram that's me and like it doesn't
I mean you look like a disheveled
version of this guy but yeah that is you
yeah they said can I please just borrow
so interesting like lesson or whatever
there is if you've got a little bit of
whatever Social Capital people are
prepared to do all sorts of stuff for
you sure without that if you didn't have
the online Persona or it wasn't well
known like what do you do then and why
is it that people are prepared to give
her help it's like an assurance of some
kind you know what I mean that's totally
true 100 and man good good for your
friend to have a what do you have a blue
check yeah it's something like that yeah
enough followers to to quantify that he
wasn't going to run away with someone's
in no shoes right yeah that wasn't who's
going to do and finally something good
came out of CrossFit that's a first but
the blue I used to be on all the dating
apps back when I was a single guy and
the girls would be like you have a blue
check why have you been talking to me
and I was like I'm a [ __ ] douche I'm
nobody but they thought the blue check
meant I was hot [ __ ] you can buy it now
you can just buy it on Twitter I know
yeah those the the fun days are over but
you should have to earn it but elon's
running out of money so I think he's
trying to figure something out yeah he's
got to get something working I've heard
you say that uh an erection is basically
an energy bar for a vampire ah yeah it's
an old tweet yeah yeah do you believe in
ghosts no no not only do I not believe
in it but I get annoyed when people do
how so well I mean come on It's too
convenient
ghosts are too convenient oh there's a
little girl living here and you're like
well wouldn't thousands of people lived
here from all the people who and why is
it like always a little girl it's never
like you know an old uh an old guy you
know it's just oh a little girl oh I can
feel her presence but why wouldn't they
be [ __ ] with you more I don't know
it's all too it's all too um easy yeah
the same friend that told me that
frogging story also told me one about
where he stayed at this place in
Birmingham in the UK and
he'd asked to stay in a particular wing
of this sort of stately home and there's
a hotel on one side that's supposed to
be really really nice and he really
wanted to stay in this other one his
manager managed to sort him in this room
and all manner of [ __ ] [ __ ] ended up
happening to him while he was in this
room but it's like a thatched roof and
stone walls yeah well it doesn't seem
like the sort of place that would have
artificially and they didn't want to let
him stay it was not you're not supposed
to stay there they had to specifically
bring a bed in just so he could do it
anyway the doors start smashing open and
closed and the windows do and then
within the next week uh a ton of [ __ ]
like it's the whole life just [ __ ]
comes crashing down around him wow and
then he's walking through Hollywood when
he gets back and this Gypsy lady comes
up to him and says sorry I don't mean to
disturb you should a ton of kids with
her uh there's like a do you know you've
got a dark shadow that's following you
and she takes him in and does the thing
and I was like [ __ ] hell and this guy
is like super super rational and uh yeah
again for me I'm very much like if I can
see it if I can't see it I won't believe
it but
[ __ ] man this I know there's something
that sort of sure really freaks me out
to hear stuff like that it really freaks
me out I believe in energies and Vibes
and all that stuff and uh you know
there's all kinds of things going on
around we're all connected blah blah but
I do think a lot of this is we live on
Earth for so long coincidence
coincidences are gonna happen but but
maybe I'm uh what do you call it
pessimist cynical are you just
continuing to focus on Comedy moving
forward then that's the the sole Pursuit
and everything gets funneled toward that
sure I mean I'd like to have a family
one day because to me that's like some
kind of toe in the normal pool you know
like my whole life is just walking
around going back normal do what a
normal person would do right now you
know I'm at a wedding like all right
don't make a pedophile joke I just get a
cup get a cup of coffee and eat some
cake and shut the [ __ ] up so yeah I
would like to have a family and not [ __ ]
that up and uh uh make but but just
continue making comedy making good
comedy and hopefully hopefully people
come out and see me I think that the the
idea of having especially as a guy now I
don't think there's as many places that
are firm for masculinity and men to kind
of stand it's like what's the role
you've outsourced resource acquisition
to [ __ ] Walmart and and Whole Foods
we've outsourced Warfare and hunting to
the police and the legal system right
like the kind of the things primarily
that we would have done ancestrally have
kind of gone sure in part and uh one of
my friends super successful guy just in
this relationship he's completely
smitten with this new girl of his and uh
he was saying it made a ton of money in
his 20s he's like man do you know what
it is I realize most of my 20s were
spent making me into the kind of dad
that I really wanted to be for my kids
oh that's nice I was like that's [ __ ]
great that's heavy it's really really
cool to think that all of the
[ __ ] ridding yourself of the juvenile
ideas that you've got yeah [ __ ] bad
habits and getting the cocaine out of
the way you know the Casual whatever and
the sense of ego and need and all that
[ __ ] and you're like oh yeah and now I
can actually be a good dad yeah but I
think for a lot of people and I'm not
this is not a knock but I think kids are
a lot of people's goal you know we were
saying we need a thing to shoot for and
strive for for a lot of people it's a a
reproductive thing that's uh they're
trying to build up and that's good
there's nothing wrong with that no I
think the problem comes when people who
don't see their kids necessarily as a
worthwhile investment have the kids and
don't have anything else because then
you don't there's just no push forward
from the parents and what do you create
you create an environment in which
listless parents create listless kids oh
totally yeah yeah and I think now we
live in this time where there's so much
modernity it's almost like the China
thing where we've given we have so much
technology everything's so easy you get
ubereats you used to have to go out and
kill a thing and now you gotta you can
just you don't have to go get it now you
don't have to go to McDonald's they'll
come to you so I think that is really as
much as that helps us in life I think
it's hurt us too
one of my friends who I spent the
weekend with uh had a got a newborn
who's six months old and weighs 25
pounds and wears two-year-olds clothes
Hmm this kid is huge it's very cute and
very well behaved and yeah very much was
like that's right that's nice that's
weird that's at what point
something happens in men and it's
happened in me where originally children
are the things that your more mature
male friends have that get in the way of
you partying with them yeah kids are
just this [ __ ] annoying way that
shakes the extra sketch and stops the
life that you used to have my business
partner can't go out and party with me
because he's got to look after the kids
right like with his wife
and then something happens that I know
like for me it was probably 30 or 32
whereas like it went from kids being
annoying to me actually looking at them
going like oh yeah they're kind of nice
I know and I can't it feels a bit I
don't know it breaks it up while I was
at Thanksgiving I don't have kids but my
in-laws have kids and we're all at that
age now and they're running around and
they're sword fighting and they got a
fake cape on you know I'm super and
they're jumping off the couch and
otherwise we'd be sitting there going
that's cold out yeah it's really uh
unseasonably warm or whatever the [ __ ]
right you see that uh the World Cup oh
how about the China with the lockdown
you know but they they they get some
energy into the room
and that's kind of nice and we did it we
had our turn now it's now it's their
turn they can interrupt Thanksgiving
yeah we used to do that we used to run
around and you know scrape our knees and
jump and climb a tree and now they're
doing it yeah it's there's something
strange about seeing that as a a guy and
remembering what it used to be like to
not be so fussed about kids yes yes and
to then see them and be like I actually
kind of like whoa whoa hey like who is
that yeah stop but at the same time at
the same time you kind of like I I know
the fatherhood [ __ ] key gets turned a
little bit more and you go I can't wait
I can't wait to be a dad man I really
really can't wait to be a dad I'm dead
yeah I don't know if I can it's not I
can't wait but I think I think it's a
good excited at the prospect yeah yeah
exactly and
uh I think it's like oh [ __ ] I lost my
train again I had a good train going run
a train I can't remember but uh I think
it's uh oh yeah I think it's weird that
when people make fun of old people you
hear that a lot oh it's like an old bag
and you're like but don't you want to be
an old bag you know like we're gonna be
that it's weird to make fun of a thing
you're gonna be so I think it's the same
with kids like we all used to go [ __ ]
kids marriage is a stupid Antiquated
idea maybe it is but uh I think you
changed like didn't you have a nightclub
at some point yeah
yeah when you were 14 you probably never
thought I'd be running a business yep
you know and so you just you go through
stages and uh it's it you shouldn't sit
around knocking stages that are up ahead
because they're gonna come yeah
everybody can guarantee there's two
choices right oh there's two options one
of them is that you end up becoming the
thing that you're currently taking a
piss out of yes and the other one is
that you die too soon to reach it
exactly neither of those feel like
something that you should really be
taking too lightly yeah there's a ageism
ageism is Big the one thing that nobody
steps in for not really I don't ever see
anyone you know even the most ridiculous
isn't obeer in the world you know
there's someone out there that's gonna
stand up yeah
I mean you know I'm for all of the jokes
that I think are funny like Joe Biden
gets like yeah age is the primary issue
that people are talking about and like
no one wants no one's defending that
even the people who are on the same side
of him are like come on the guy's like
[ __ ] 100. I know I think it's because
it's the same way you can [ __ ] on kids
uh [ __ ] kids huh it's because we were
kids and we will be old so I think it
takes a little of a sting out of it when
you will be that thing you're not gonna
be black you know but you will be old
you couldn't say that but Michael
Jackson ah dollars all yeah yeah good
point good point well gay
also actually there's a lot of these
that we can become yeah maybe the
world's just free-flowing as well as we
think it is convert to Judaism or the
all of the above um yeah it's it's
strange to think about the the whole
like ageism and and an aging out thing
speaking as well about sort of taking
the piss out of it do you know why or
one of the evolutionary explanations for
why we have menopause or why women go
through menopause no so it's called the
uh grandmother hypothesis so you can
imagine
women contribute kids after they get to
a certain age they'll contribute kids to
the tribe and you need that because you
need the tribe to keep them moving
forward you need to continue to fill
them as people age out and die and get
gored by a mammoth or whatever but after
a certain age
women it turns out that it's very hard
to raise kids so you need to have uh
parenting shared between a lot of the
women and the men contributes sometimes
as well but if every woman continue to
just add more mouths to feed you would
end up with more mouths than there are
energy to be able to give to them so
what you actually need is for women who
still have the maternal mothering
impulse and they're invested in their
daughters and then their daughter's
daughters but are not adding more mouths
into that pool to be fed so the
grandmother would be able to contribute
to caring and Gathering and helping
[ __ ] sort [ __ ] but doesn't continue
to add to more children and called the
grandmother hypothesis I like it and it
feels pretty good yeah now what does
that say for Viagra though
because we can we our dicks stopped
working eventually you know to a degree
and you artificially give it another bit
of juice is that is that bad for the uh
for the society
I didn't well I mean I guess you can
wear a condom male sperm does decrease
in terms of quality it does decrease
after after a certain time uh that being
said my friend who's got the the baby
who is uh very large and pretty cute uh
is in his 60s what yeah wow baby's
perfect super super cute uh amazing dad
amazing mum you go
I don't know man like yeah technology
yeah I guess so I mean look at Nick
Cannon who's that oh who's Nick Cannon
he's a gun he's an Entertainer but he's
one of these guys he's all about
procreating and he I think he has
15 kids or something
Wow's got ten elon's got ten he's
another one of these procreating guys so
I don't know I think it's at some point
it's kind of child abuse
what do you mean well maybe elon's
obviously a zillionaire so he can afford
it but I think
you know you want to be able to be
around for the kids see the kids raise
the kids get to know the kids but if you
have that many and you work as hard as
he does it feels like it's tough to get
to know them all you're going to spread
the resources a little bit too yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you're
gonna Farm it out to Mom or nanny or a
girlfriend or whoever yeah so I don't
know I I would like to have the amount
of kids I can actually be there for yeah
I think I think that seems to make sense
look dude let's bring this one home I
really appreciate you thank you for
seeing me before you show tonight thank
you for having me and uh it's cool I've
been watching on YouTube so it's fun to
talk to you thank you uh where should
people go they want to check out the
[ __ ] you do where should they go uh
markdormancomedy.com for dates and I
have a pie I have two pods we might be
drunk and uh Tuesdays with stories and
I'll see you on the road
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]